I would say that Colin Kaepernick is the
Meghan Markle of the sports world but
that wouldn't be quite accurate sure
like Markle he's a wealthy privileged
brat just as white as he is black but
nonetheless obsessed with his entirely
imagined racial victimhood
um so that's similar but there are some
crucial caveats first for one thing
Kaepernick can't really be the Markle of
the sports world because he isn't an
athlete unless you account the
oppression Olympics as an actual sport
which Perhaps it is or one day will be
and for another two is credit he didn't
have to marry into his victimhood unlike
Markle Colin Kaepernick isn't riding
anyone's coattails he achieved his
status as faux martyr and insufferable
obnoxious prick all on his own
actually the more I think about it he we
we might say that Kaepernick is sort of
Megan and Harry combined if you mix the
two Royal whiners together and you
combine their powers you end up with
Kaepernick he's like he's like the
self-victimizing Megazord he has
markle's fake racial grievances but he
also has Harry's disloyalty and his
pension for um throwing his own family
onto the bus and driving over them and
then backing up and driving over them
again and then again and again and again
he is such a perfect amalgamation of the
two such a manifestation of the worst
aspects of both of them they almost
wonder whether by some strange Time Warp
he might actually be their child is
Kaepernick the adult son of Harry and
Megan who has come back in time to
experience and exploit this era of woke
victimhood that's a possibility we need
to discuss there's there's a conspiracy
theory I can get on board with maybe or
at least it's just a screenplay someone
should write at the very least
but assuming that Kaepernick is not a
victimhood chasing time traveler then
the real story is that he was conceived
by a white woman and a black man and he
was then abandoned by his black father
put up for adoption as an infant and
taken in by a white couple his white
adoptive parents raised him gave him a
blessed and comfortable life supported
him loved him and now after all of that
they find themselves somehow the objects
of their adopted son's animosity
that is whenever he has something to
promote at least
and this week he's promoting a new book
which means they're going right into the
bus yet again here's the New York Post
report says controversial football star
Colin Kaepernick accused his white
adoptive parents of perpetuating racism
in a new interview the former NFL star
told CBS Chicago that he struggled
growing up in a problematic household a
through line he details in his upcoming
graphic novel changed the game graphic
novel tells the story of Kaepernick's
Journey from high school into his
storied athletic career that well
storied athletic careers oh look it's uh
maybe a little bit overstating it that
heavily centers around his lack of
choice in his future his parents
particularly tried to steer him in a
Direction they thought was best which
led to several fights between them and
their adopted son
can you imagine that parents tried to
steer their child in the direction they
think is best what parent would ever do
that
here's a clip of the interview check it
out
who's spreading a message of empowerment
in his new graphic novel change the game
written with author and University of
Chicago Professor Eve L Ewing I love how
you depict yourself in this book not as
some big shot hero but as a shy insecure
high schooler like we all were
I mean I'm speaking for you
no absolutely
growing up I was a
uh I think still have a pretty
introverted person I hope it's true to
form and that's just kind of how I
navigate the world it's his true High
School Coming of Age story his journey
embracing his Blackness despite
resistance from many including his white
adoptive parents I know my parents love
me but there were still very problematic
things that
I went through I think it was important
to show that no this can happen in your
own home and how we move forward
collectively while addressing the racism
that is being perpetuated he took cues
from a con basketball
Iverson who he said wore his Blackness
like a suit of armor and teenage
Kaepernick wanted cornrows to match he's
getting what roles his mom asked oh your
hair is not professional oh you look
like a little Thug
said that to you yeah and those become
spaces where it's like okay how do I
navigate the situation now but it also
has informed why I have my hair long
today the grown-up version of Eve wanted
to go back in time and give young Colin
a lot of hugs and I was really moved and
saddened by the level of kind of
self-awareness that he had to develop at
a very young age without a lot of
guidance now uh I certainly am not
making any excuses for this guy he's a
scumbag of the lowest kind there's no
getting around that
but you can also tell that the man has
been severely brainwashed and as time
goes on with each successive interview
he sounds more and more like like a 55
year old white woman holding a corporate
diversity seminar we just listened to
the words and the phrases that he uses
problematic
perpetuating racism move forward
collectively and then my favorite
navigate these spaces how do we navigate
these spaces
no human being naturally speaks that way
okay a former athlete especially does
not speak that way you're not going to
hear a football player in the locker
room saying to his teammates listen
fellas there's a lot of problematic
Behavior going on in here we really need
to figure out how to navigate these
spaces so we can move forward
collectively respecting each other's
lived experiences so that we can unpack
our oppression and curate an
understanding of our intersectional
realities and together come up with
solution-oriented perspectives liberated
from our post-colonial trauma
it's just not how human beings speak
okay rather it's how a Dei diversity you
know uh robot is programmed
and that's what Colin Kaepernick has
become basically
so what is his complaint against his
parents yes they took him in yes they
raised and loved him yes they they gave
him a wonderful and privileged life yes
they supported him and they set him up
for Success yes they did everything for
him
but they criticized his hairstyle so all
of that is irrelevant
I mean that is that is a resentment he
holds with him today he he still
determines how he Styles his hair today
based on what his parents told him not
to do when he was a teenager
now he has a point though I will admit I
mean it really is unprecedented for
parents to complain about their
children's hairstyles
right it's not like literally every
parent on Earth has this kind of
conversation with their teenage children
it's not like every parent I mean
literally every parent white or black or
whatever color has to at some point give
their child a lecture about the
importance of maintaining a professional
haircut and and appearance
actually come to think of it um it's not
entirely unprecedented so I guess Colin
Kaepernick went through this and then
and then the only other person in in the
history of the world was me because I
could remember can remember when I first
started developing facial hair so I
would have been about three or four at
the time and I wanted to grow a goatee
but my dad he he took one look at what I
was trying to do there and he told me
that it looks ridiculous and
unacceptable his words exactly and
forced me to shave so
when a CBS gonna interview me so I can
tell my story where is my book deal to
unpack my trauma
but then again I wouldn't take that book
deal even if it was offered because I'd
rather be broke and homeless than earn
money by publicly stabbing my own family
in the back
of all the ways to earn money that is
among the most disgraceful it's worse
than prostitution perhaps it's perhaps
it's a type of prostitution actually
Colin Kaepernick is a in his own
way prostituting himself by selling his
Integrity selling out his own family in
exchange for victim points
now it's well established of course that
um that Kaepernick's victimhood
narrative is
totally fanciful he grew up comfortable
he became a professional athlete he
decided to transition to social justice
Warrior after his playing career had
taken a nosedive based on his poor
performance after he got benched uh for
uh you know for for Blaine Gabbert which
is pretty much the the the worst
humiliation a football player can
possibly experience
and then that happens and he becomes a
social justice Warrior and through his
social justice charade finds wealth and
fame far beyond anything the NFL could
ever provide for him
he has not been
disadvantaged by his quote unquote
blackness
but rather he has profited immensely
from it here's an indisputable fact okay
this could not be disputed if everything
about Kaepernick was the same
except that he was fully white rather
than just half white okay if his
deadbeat biological father was white
instead of black let's say then
Kaepernick would today at the age of 35
or 36 however old he is he would today
be an obscure washed out backup
quarterback with um with a with a a net
worth and profile barely a fraction of
what it currently is
you wouldn't have any endorsements you
wouldn't have any book deals he wouldn't
have any Netflix series
at the very best he'd appear on ESPN
occasionally to debate the other Talking
Heads about whether uh Joe burrow has a
higher ceiling than Patrick Mahomes or
whatever
more likely he'd have drifted off into
complete obscurity by now and maybe he'd
own a strip mall or a car dealership or
something
his Blackness has opened up very
lucrative doors that wouldn't exist
without it
that's indisputable the the fully white
version of Colin Kaepernick is in a much
worse spot today
than the half white version
so we don't need to analyze his
victimhood claims they're utterly bogus
they're laughable on their face
instead what we should focus on when it
comes to Kaepernick
is his absolute lack of gratitude
and in this way he is a microcosm or One
symptom of a culture-wide epidemic and
that epidemic is ingratitude
you cannot have a functioning Society
without a rich atmosphere of gratitude
gratitude felt and demonstrated by the
younger Generations towards those who
came before and gave them everything
that they have and this gratitude should
be especially extended to uh to and
begin with your family and your direct
benefactors
but it should go beyond that to your
nation and your nation's forebears
now this doesn't mean that you have to
pretend that your family was perfect or
your country is perfect
gratitude doesn't require Perfection it
shouldn't require it
what it means is that you recognize what
was built for you what was provided to
you what sacrifices were made for you
and for your sake that that and that
this recognition breeds respect and
loyalty and humility
and a palpable sense of thankfulness
where would Kaepernick be if not for his
adoptive parents
where would he be if he'd been born in
another country
may you take either his adoptive parents
or his country out of the equation
is there any chance he'd have a better
life right now
that's inconceivable
there's a very good chance he'd be
living in the gutter or dead in it
without the very people and the Very
Nation he can't stop complaining about
does he ever acknowledge that ever does
he ever say it out loud do any of these
self-victimizing drama queens ever
acknowledge that
of course they don't gratitude destroys
the grift
and it's much more profitable to be a
rotten disloyal little punk
than it is to be grateful and humble
much more profitable to be a spoiled
child who's never satisfied no matter
how much he has given
no matter what anyone does for him
and that is Kaepernick in a nutshell
but he is right about one thing this
country does have some serious problems
big problems
and one of the biggest one of the
biggest problems
is that it produces people like him
that'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block and
become a member today by using Code
Walsh at checkout for two months free on
all annual plans hope to see you over
there if not talk to you on Monday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]